hey everyone i'm colin jost and i'm here
on set with GQ welcome favorite
interaction with Lauren Michaels oh can
I say feelings probably not my favorite
interaction with Lorne Michaels I think
one time he's a good job and I almost
cried he sees this I don't want I don't
want to reveal too much about how I
perceive the world his world in my world
like well I walk to goodnights
and I think maybe I'll get a pat on the
back or my friend becbennett will get a
pat on the back but one of us won't
and then we'll like have to like talk
about it after fact like we're do wrong
when I can pat on the back when I did
the last baby boss sketch with Cameron
Diaz there's a point where like I slide
down the stairs and he's like we can see
your shin guards coming out of your
pants I was like well I'll take the
lower ones off and he was like well I
don't want you to get first and he said
that in front of everybody and I was
like don't worry Lauren I won't get hurt
thanks boss my favorite interactions
with Lorne Michaels was probably one
time we were drinking and we were
talking about Richard Pryor and he's
telling me some food Richard Pryor
stories he remembers Richard Pryor when
he hosted obviously from the 70s and
stuff so as a stand-up Bilbo is kind of
the best ones when you hear like stories
of great commitment for a while I Lorne
Michaels would butt-dial me and it's
different like if you get butt dialed by
your parents because you after two
seconds of silence you just hang up but
when Lauren calls you you really wait to
see if it might be something important
and you're like wait please are you sure
everything's okay have you been
kidnapped is everything okay for more
videos like this subscribe to the GQ
channel